Un nouveau fléau ravage youtube
C'est Zenyatta qui vous le dis pu**** de me***
*Musique Overwatch* *Attaque Zenyatta*
Voilà c'est mon imitation de Zenyatta
Ok on redevient sérieux !
Depuis plusieurs mois une bonne partie de la communauté
met les youtubeurs en...
PLS
*cri*
Vous voulez savoir pourquoi ?
Les commentaires !
*Fracas*
*Lit le commentaire*
Quoi !?
Pourquoi je .. c'est un piège !
Oh génial haha
*Lit le commentaire*
*Musique de thug*
Ooh...
*Lit le commentaire*
Vous..
Oh j'suis flatté ! Oh j'te met un pouce vert pu****
*Lit le commentaire*
Putain mais mec carrément !
Maintenant faut carrément se faire a trouver le 9ème mot
5, 6, 7, 8... 9
Moi
Et en plus il est narcissique !
*Lit le commentaire*
Ah parce qu'en fait il lui a écrasé la tête du coup ça a fait des lettres au pif comme ça
Pu**** hyper drôle, pouce vert
Il faut que ça cesse !
Les commentaires ne doivent pas être un concours de bite !
"Eh j'ai eu 200 j'aimes sur mon commentaire"
"Bah moi j'en ai eu 400 sur son avant-dernière vidéo"
"Oh starfoullah t'es un ouf !"
Votre attention s'il vous plaît !
Derrière cette intro euh ... de me*** *rigole*
se cache un vrai message.
ça fait pas mal de temps que je ne lis plus les commentaires youtube
Et pourquoi je ne les lis plus, c'est extrêmement simple
c'est parce qu'en fait je n'y trouve plus de plaisir a les lire étant donné que les gens
ne parlent plus des vidéos ou de eux ce qu'ils aiment
ou il interagissent plus par rapport a ce que j'ai dis dans la vidéo
ou par rapport au jeu, ou à n'importe quoi !
Les 9/10eme des commentaires sont juste des gens
(alors attention je parle des top commentaires
ceux sur lesquels les gens ont mis un gros pouce vert en disant "j'acquiesce ce commentaire !" )
Et bien ce ne sont que des commentaires à base de concours de bite
C'est à dire les commentaires fait pour avoir le plus de "j'aime" possible
On en a eu quelques uns là, y en a environ 600 milliards d'autres
qu'on voit et revoit sur youtube
"j'vais aller aux toilettes, quand je reviendrais ce commentaire aura fait le buzz"
"allez j'vais avoir au mins 400 j'aimes hein !"
"Ah devant Matthieu je vais pouvoir me la péter !"
Du coup il n'y a plus aucun plaisir a lire ces commentaires
Mais quand on lit plus les commentaires on a un peu moins de plaisir a faire des vidéos
Alors oui ya les vus, ça fait beaucoup de vus etc, donc tu te dis que ça plait aux gens mais
moi ce que j'ai envie de voir c'est des gens qui sortent des trucs marrants
dans les commentaires mais qui sortent des blagues en rapport avec la vidéo
avec l'univers, pas des gars qui sortent des blagues euh ...
"universelles" juste pour avoir des pouces verts
Ouais, j'trouve que les temps ont un peu changés maintenant c'est de pire en pire sur toutes les vidéos Youtube
je retrouve tout le temps ces commentaires en top commentaire qui ont 1 milliard de pouces verts
et ceux qui sont mis en valeur malheureusement par Youtube
ce qui est d'ailleurs totalement mal foutu
Mais ce qui est dégueulasse,
c'est que ces gens qui postent les commentaires un peu nuls
sont en vrai qu'une minorité, mais une minorité assez suffisante pour que
ces commentaire aient autant de pouces verts et soient mis en avant
Actuellement je modère ça comme je peux dès que je vais sur une vidéo je bannis
tous les mecs qui mettent des commentaires comme ça
J'ai même mis certains mots qu'on retrouvent beaucoup dans ces commentaires là
dans les mots bannis de la chaîne
ce qui veut dire que leurs commentaires ne passent pas quand ils les postent
mais ça change rien on en est toujours là et
je craque mon slip pu****
J'suis un thug ! J'suis entrain d'organiser une révolution !
En vrai y a rien d'organiser c'est juste que j'fais ça parce que moi ça me fait chier
et je suis sûr et certain que les 99% des gens qui mettent des commentaires cools ça les fait encore plus chier que moi
Parce que eux postent des trucs cools, ils ont envie d’interagir avec les autres gens qui regardent la vidéo et même avec moi
et ils peuvent pas parce que leurs commentaires sont complètement zappés à cause des commentaires pourris
qui veulent des likes là !
J'sais pas ya des gens qui ont besoin d'un certaine reconnaissance
pour eux avoir des j'aimes c'est avoir fait un gros buzz je sais pas je comprend pas
Enfin bref je voulais vous faire passer ce p'tit message parce que c'est un truc qui m'emmerde un peu
et j'pense même à désactiver les commentaires sur mes vidéos si ça continue parce que c'est...
ça n'a plus de sens, je les lis plus, autant les désactivés
et qu'on fasse ça ailleurs autrement j'en sais rien
mais qu'on trouve un truc
Regardez le commentaire que j'ai lu tout à l'heure, ya exactement le même là !
sauf que lui il a pas eu le droit aux pouces verts parce que 600 personnes ont mis ce commentaire avant lui
Du coup le mot "père" je vais devoir le mettre dans les mots bannis de ma chaîne
Pour que tous les commentaires qui contiennent le mot "père" soient dégagés de la chaîne
Mais c'est complètement con parce qu'un gars peut avoir envie de parler de son père
dans les commentaires
et du coup son commentaire à lui aussi il dégagera !
Vous comprenez la problématique c'est terrible ce qu'il se passe aujourd'hui
Donc ouais j'suis un peu triste en voyant cet espace destiné à l'interaction entre les gens,
à créer une vraie ambiance cool se décliner jour après jour
jusqu'à devenir une véritable poubelle de gens qui veulent juste avoir des j'aimes sur leur commentaire
en plus ça sert a rien, j'veux dire ça sert à rien d'avoir des j'aimes sur un commentaire
normalement avoirs des j'aimes sur un commentaire c'est pour que le créateur de la vidéo
ait une chance de voir ton commentaire
Mais quand ton commentaire n'a rien à voir avec la vidéo ou le mec,
qu'est ce que ça peut te foutre qu'il le voit ou pas ?
Bref les amis
une nouvelle ère commence
C'est Sylavanas qui le dit
Mais j'espère qu'à partir de maintenant ça va un peu se calmer
Que le fait de mettre des avis négatifs sur un commentaire ça le dégagera complètement
Et que l'espace commentaire redeviendra un espace plutôt cool
Y aura toujours des p'tits truc qui iront pas, c'est internet c'est normal mais..
voilà que ce soit moins abusé
Parce que je me souvient qu'avant quand je lisais des commentaires
y avait des trucs supers drôles, des gens qui postaient des trucs gentils
des gens qui postaient des critiques ou qui disaient "oh j'ai adoré ça, j'aime bien, oh faisons ci..."
Voilà il y avait des vraies interactions , des vraies idées, des vrais trucs cool qui avaient du sens finalement dans les commentaires
et que là ça devient juste un gros débarras de me***
Enfin non ! Mais le peu de me*** qu'il y a, c'est ça qui est mis en avant et c'est un gros problème
C'est cool de réagir à une vidéo avec d'autres gens dans les commentaires c'est toujours cool
Et ce truc là vient entraver ça donc écoutez je compte sur vous pour mettre des gros pouces rouges
sur les commentaires qui ont plein de pouces verts et qui sont nul à chi**
on va appeler ça les commentaires "j'veux faire le buzz bitch"
et bah on va faire le buzz dans ta chambre sous ta couette voilà
et laisse Youtube mettre en avant les commentaires constructifs et sympas plutôt que les tiens
Reste sous ta couette !!!
Tu... !
Tu sors... ! J'vais l'marave... j'vais l'marav !!
Voilà j'avais besoin d'en parler euh... finalement vous avez été mon psy aujourd'hui
C'étais une super séance !
Combien je vous doit du coup ?
10 cent... 400€ la séance ? Bon...
Bon bah merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère que ça changera un minimum, en fait si on agit tous
c'est sûr et certain que ça va changer en fait
y a pas de question qui se pose
En tous cas merci a tous les autres et c'est la put*** de grande majorité qui postent des commentaires supers cool sur les vidéos
je les lis, c'est vrai que je répond jamais j'suis un conn***
Mais j'en lis vraiment une bonne partie et c'est toujours un moment de plaisir donc merci merci merci
on se retrouve très vite pour une prochaine vidéo
le coup d'état est terminé c'est bon